i saw someone say when tyron got knocked
out his ass jiggled as well
it's so mean
[Applause]
man that was a
crazy knockout that clip what a clip
holy fudge
yeah but i think it was kind of
interesting um a lot of things are
interesting about it and i know everyone
would be like don't [ __ ] uh
uh
he got he's definitely gotten a lot
better jake paul yeah and
i think a lot of people
last time i talked about this they
confused
you know a lot of his fans got like
sensitive about what i was saying
because i think what i was trying to say
was he has a right hand but
he hasn't shown anything that's like oh
like
this guy is a phenomenal boxer right
strictly speaking on like his footwork
and you know
to me he doesn't seem like a natural
like he's like an athlete though he's
like committed to learning and like
getting better at it but to me he's not
like a dude who gets in there and he's
like really light on his feet just
naturally and it's just like oh man this
dude is whatever
um
it was really funny how many people were
like this is rigged
this is rigged i mean why would you like
if it's rigged why would you agree to
being knocked out like that not like
that yeah [ __ ] no yeah if it's rigged
you're just gonna lose on points and
then that's it
another thing i thought was interesting
was i think his natural expression and
people were like oh he gassed out he
gassed that i don't think he gassed out
i think he just breathes like that i
think he just hangs his mouth open and
that's just how he is
um
he's still like when it got spicy he
didn't really look that put together
um
did it get spicy i don't know i watched
so it was a win for me that i didn't
know was going on but then afterwards i
was like i check out the highlights
another i googled it i watched the
youtube video and it was like
i don't know if it was just a bad edit
or what but the guy was like
cutting to all the action
no there wasn't a lot of action it was
none of them hugging it was really
really bad it was an awful fight and i
think it was because
jake was planning on the counter punch
he was trying to bait him in so he
wasn't doing a lot of work like jabbing
him up and looking busy
his strategy was like really simple it
was like jab a little and then like he's
kind of like
backing up or getting tyron to to bite
and tyron he just
no matter what training he does
he just looks the same like he does that
[ __ ] wide-ass flat-footed stance his
hands are like up here
and i think
his whole
you know the way he's fought his whole
life is being able to do this like crazy
shuffle forward and spark people with
that right hand so
i just think it was a great match up for
jake
because he's like all right he hit me
with the hardest [ __ ] and i was all
right
as long as that doesn't happen to me
i'll be okay yeah the most action was
tyron accidentally elbowed him
yeah i saw that one cut him open yeah i
saw that um it was a headbutt wasn't it
didn't he do that too no they kept
saying it was a head butt and
tyron like or i guess you call a
headbutt because jake like dipped down
but tyron like he he covered up and like
his elbow
gotcha i'm pretty sure clearly like
contacts his forehead
but all that to say
i still feel like
i think every i think here's what's
interesting about you not knowing about
the fight most people didn't know i
found it a couple days ago yeah
because i just happen to be like
cruising some like boxing threat on
twitter and then someone's like oh jake
paul such and such i thought that was
wild i'm like damn it's not even on my
discover page yeah not until like the
day of
and um
it's interesting because i think even
the tommy fury fight
people are saying tommy ferry's a bigger
draw i thought he was less of a draw
i i you know i feel like we only heard
about it
because it was tyron maybe yeah
uh
it's really grim when like you look at
all the stuff leading up like jake
bought him a
rolex know that whole just
it's grim because it like worked
yeah but it
it yeah at the end of the day he's he's
only like five fights in and
he's doing what you're supposed to
unboxing which is like you line up
you line up matches that
work for you and i think
he's still just knocked out a 40 year
old man who doesn't really know how to
box yeah and boxing i think that's a
great thing to illustrate is that boxing
and mma are not the same yeah
so that's why jake is so confident being
like i'll fight moz vidal i'll fight
whoever
um because for them to adapt to strictly
boxing it's just it's not it's not the
same
so i do think tommy
is going to be tough for him though
but he could win is it going to happen
i think it will
um
and what's the story he said he had like
concussions or some [ __ ]
i don't know i didn't pay attention to
any of that i just you know i definitely
legally streamed the fight
you legally stream i definitely legally
streamed the fight you legally streamed
it from the
pay-per-view that you bought yeah okay
good yeah i definitely legally paid for
the fight that's good to know yeah
that's really good to know
yeah i mean
i think the interesting thing is no one
gave a [ __ ] and i really think it'd be
harder for anyone to give a [ __ ] about
the next one i actually think those
first couple fights he had were only so
big
because of like the pandemic
like he kind of hit it at the perfect
time or everyone's kind of just in the
house yeah bored yeah and i mean it
still was like a pact
venue or whatever like stadium they have
it looked like it was packed
oh yeah no they definitely sold tickets
i'm not saying that it the the
the hype has died off personally i think
when you compare it to the first one
it's a flawed comparison because i think
that first one was like exponential
numbers that anyone would struggle to
hit normally
so
but i think the thing that everyone is
just gonna have to accept is everyone
has to get jake paul tattoos
and this kid is
he's punching his way into boxing well
we'll see i mean the next one
i think whatever boxer if he fights a
combatant boxer in the next three fights
i don't know how well he'll do i really
don't because yeah he sparked out tyron
but like tyron exactly what you said
would just like lock up with them and
they just hug
and then beautiful moments
commentators are so funny because
they were
even jake jake didn't really show a lot
and they were like none of these guys
want to fight
and then at the end of rounds they'd be
like who'd you give that to like i gave
it to neither of them
like they were so
over it
i think everyone's pretty checked out
that's what i mean is even on the third
one even
here's the crazy part i almost feel that
even if he gets knocked out no one cares
yeah
you know yeah
it's like who gives a [ __ ]
which is uh a win for him it is yeah i
think that's a good
point about culture and social media is
that
you know now we're so depressed we're at
the point that if jake paul got knocked
out we'd all just shrug ourselves
it's like huh yeah and it was gonna
happen eventually yeah yeah
yeah i'm saying it's a win for him not
to be knocked out when people really
wanted him to be knocked out oh yeah
yeah yeah
yeah now he's like yeah he's got to the
point where
it's like
yeah even if he does everyone's kind of
like oh well
it's okay
you know really
yeah that happened last night oh
huh i think i saw a clip of that on
twitter yeah
literally yeah i think jake paul in some
ways kind of like limp bizkit
like it just feels like every few years
there needs to be like sort of like a
tattooed
guy who's like really
like some tattooed white guy who needs
to be really extra okay and that was
like fred durst for a while yeah
who else
um i think mgk qualifies a little bit
okay yeah that's fair and then like jake
is kind of like his own breed of that so
i kind of feel like
you know i used to think oh who's like a
jake paul fan who could be an adult jake
paul fan i'm like oh yeah it's anyone
who would have liked limp bizkit yeah
early 2000s but is just born now yeah
you know like there's a dude who woke up
this morning and put on his jake paul
shirt and was like my boy he did that
[ __ ] dude yeah there's still there's
grown men still referring to themselves
as jake paulers yeah
what i love is that
we share something with jake what you
can't escape you're you're early
creative yeah you just can't yeah and
ariel alwany in the middle of the ring
after knocking out tyron woodley i think
almost it was almost the only thing that
could demote jake paul's happiness what
did he say
would you say it's every day then
no way something like that
and and you saw it
that was actually the like you know for
all the fighting we've seen jake do
that's the most stunned i think we've
ever seen him went
it's every day bro oh
weirdly i had to do it weirdly i felt
for him yeah exactly we could we could
we could make like a
you know like a box office smash movie
right
and
you know we'd be we'd be accepting our
speech
at uh
at the oscars is that the one
one of them one of them the grammys
that our pr firm paid us yeah to be at
and the person reading the thing will be
like now that's not cringed at all it's
cody calling noel miller coming up here
guys we're like
oh no no no no you're being too generous
you know what they say what
i guess it pays to keep your dick fat
yeah yeah i had someone say that to me
at a bar the other day he could always
like keep your dick fat bro and i was
like
away from me